can't get a word in edgeways here it's
London Fashion Week they're all talking
hemlines and goodness knows what here
but Lucy Carter entertainment
correspondent being down there and seen
it and high influential how important is
London Fashion Week well very
influential and they've had one of the
best weeks they've ever had in terms of
press and also buyers they've had more
American department store buyers than
ever before which is very important for
the British designers because that's one
of their key market you've had about 200
designers showing including Tom Ford
it's the first time he's been here and
also I think we've got some shots of the
Burberry fashion show which is always
the glitziest than the most glamorous
and really pulls in the stars you had
Sienna Miller Samantha Cameron Kanye
West Anna Wintour and also a Mario
Testino the famous fashion photographer
and we've been speaking to him and he's
been saying that London is a fashion
capital and it really is standing up
against the other fashion capitals of
the world he says Britain is where it is
at the moment the truth is that all the
ideas come out of here and before they
used to be picked up by every other
descended from around the world diluted
and communicated to the world and other
people were making all the money and
maybe now it's becoming a lot more
important I think that Burberry in a way
bringing their shows back to England has
been very important because they've
managed to you know bring the attention
back here that England isn't only a half
of ideas but it's also a business and
there's an industry working and people
are making it happen well I'm a bit of a
fashion guru myself I advise all this
guy lady presenters us to want to wear
that's not a joke either yeah that's why
we're slashing today but but I'm looking
at this for everyone and I'm guessing
ladies that there's not much that rings
your bell there no it's hideous you say
that now but actually by the time it is
the spring summer 2012 collection by the
time it comes around I'm sure we'll all
be loving it really no ways that
because Jackie won't i were an
antibiotic implored but he always looks
completely bored Jackie how do you tell
the difference his girlfriend I think
likes fashion Kim she looks I but she's
in burberry like her coach it couldn't
be there you go by the time it filters
down to the high street anyway my sort
of change in its look but that whole
ankle boots kind of dress you know dress
and skirt thing I'm not sure about
personally well actually they're saying
it's knee-high boots with the long
dresses this I think the ankle put your
face use Pippa Middleton if I'm if I'm
not mistaken so let's see Pippa
Middleton oh those the time that will be
her but that's certain they're bears
yeah Pippa Middleton's really get a look
at her ankle say we normally used to
look another no I'm sorry I'm sorry it
doesn't pretty was at the Alice
Temperley shows but then who's looking
at her ankles that's the thing Wow I
think you hit the nail and heard that
but paper middleton wars at london
fashion week but kate wasn't at london
fashion week but the point is that Kate
is so influential in British fashion at
the moment then we've got some pictures
of her engagements where she wore a blue
ice address there's there'll be lots of
flashes on this and but when she wore
this that dress sold out in hours yeah
and it also boosted the brand i sir by
about forty five percent and obviously
wish when she wore Alexander McQueen to
her wedding it was priceless PR around
the world and but you say that did I not
read last week that American buyers of
their big stores say that that she
doesn't cause any ripple there they
don't think they think she's a trend
follower the rot rather than a
trendsetter yes a big American fashion
east the last week said that Kate
Middleton is someone you wouldn't look
twice at in the street and this might be
blind well exactly I didn't know who he
sees on the street but i certainly don't
see people like her but that it there
has been a debate as to whether she's a
style icon or just a style follower ok
well let's ask her ordinary housewives
assembled beside you there I'm Charlotte
first of all a follower or a leader well
I think she's kind of trying to calm her
own nation [ __ ] I think she's bringing
together quite well the whole High
Street thing and just representing for
every day she like it you're like way
too she would enter in shoes so yeah
Charlotte likes it so much she went out
and bought
engage him address what color did it and
she did she did was wearing it yesterday
the peacock grew yeah that's it that's
the same or trades that she is a style
icon because if you look at someone like
Cheryl Cole now she's changed her style
because she's been dressed to be that
way whereas Kate Middleton has always
stuck to her own star and therefore I
see him as a style icon do you think
someone like shackles more style victim
yeah yeah before and after yeah in fact
she wears quite a lot a lot of high
street clothes that's what I yes she
wears high C and high-end designers mmm
does it really well very big economists
has said that she's going to be worth
about 15 billion to the high street and
witches designers buy something like
2014 so her influence and the the effect
that she's having on Britain in terms of
fashion it is very influenced and she's
always in the American papers or the New
York papers she definitely was in all
the time and people talk about her all
the time and she's on TV all the time so
I don't know what that fashion writer
was talking about exactly a name is
Samantha Cameron sorry it's not the
Cameron and also michelle obama what
they wear people watch comments on and
then go and buy em well that's what
Charlotte said it will all be diluted
the time it gets the high street and
you'll all be wearing it by Christmas we
should be wearing burberry jacket
sometimes seen because Kate Middleton
when she visited Northern Ireland she
was wearing a berber jacket very good
I'd like to see him in ankle boots not
hilarious